The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ANA BELL: Let's walk through it.
We have three lists.
L1 is equal to [re].
L2 is equal to [mi].
L3 is equal to [do].
L4 is equal to-- let's just do
what it says here-- L1 plus L2.
So it's going to be the list
[re, mi]-- uh, yeah, mi.
Now, extend() is going
to mutate the list.
So that means L3 is going to
be extended by whatever L4 is.
So L3 is going to be-- OK,
what did it have originally?
It had do.
And then, it's
going to be extended
by all of the elements inside
L4, which is re, mi, like that.
And once I've mutated
it, the old version of L3
is gone, right?
This is the L3 down here
that I'm going to work with.
L3.sort() is going to
sort alphabetically.
So that's [do, mi, re].
Yep.
And sort() also
mutates the list.
So the old version of
the list I have is gone.
del is going to also
mutate the list.
So it's going to look
in L3, look at index 0,
and it's going to
delete that-- it's
going to delete that element.
So it's going to mutate L3.
And it's going to
be [mi, re], OK?
And once again, I've
mutated the list.
So the old version's gone.
And lastly-- this is a tricky
part-- I'm going to append,
to my current L3, which looks
like this, another list.
So to L3, I'm
appending another list.
So this is going to be
the list [fa, la], OK?
So [mi, re], and then the
list [fa, la] is the answer,
which is red-- no, sorry, blue.
Good, you had me scared.
OK.
Perfect.
So if you didn't
get this, I would
suggest you go through
the Python tutor
or you just trace it out by
hand, just like I just did.
And hopefully it'll
be apparent, the more
exercises you do with lists,
what exactly is going on.
OK.